yo guys what's up prestige here again
today with a little more ft baby ramen
all day that's probably like
all right yo what's up guys seal face
i'm still samuel jackson i really don't
know what i'm gonna remember to change
that but yo guys what's up this is
another the second episode of stb
and yeah i guess we can just look right
into it oh i just ate all my blueberries
thank you
let's do some iron flesh in there all
right
so
i've made all these i'm doing okay
today we are going to attempt to make a
generator
and attempt to make a
bad box
no no
if we're gonna tend to make a generator
and or attempt to make
the uh smeltery controller i don't know
what it does but it's another controller
and i want to make it
so we're going to need some eye we're
going to need to go mine in a bit so
i'm going to need some more wood and i
don't know what my friends going lower
on the frames so i don't know what's
with that but yeah let's let's pick up
some wood before we let's let's use some
of this rubber wood because i don't have
too much soccer or wood left i think
we're back to the frames
all right so now i think
it'd be smart
to make a house mine since house mines
are always good
so for now i'll make it one circus i
might go back and make it to two
staircases later on
uh but i know you guys don't want to see
that so also i think i think i'm going
to talk a little bit about i'm going to
have a little story time this was
learning we're going to talk about black
friday
now well my view of black friday i
should say since some of you guys might
be like i have an opposing people just
fine uh i'll just share my view all
right so my view of black friday is that
it's pretty dumb if you ask me uh if you
don't live in america you probably don't
experience this
um but as an american things we have
thanksgiving
and i know you don't experience that uh
that
specific holiday
but uh you might you might like uh
that i'm assuming you're gonna know
about that one more
so
we have we have thanksgiving and then
the day after or it's usually the day
after all the stores decide that oh
we're gonna make
crazy deals so i get this tv 80 off
stuff like that
and
so that's the day after thanksgiving so
the day after we're like oh we're
thankful for stuff we go out and buy
more stuff and
it wouldn't be
excuse me it wouldn't be
terrible
if uh it was just sales but the people
go really uh
really into it like
i think every single year black friday
that i i
like
have known what black friday is somebody
has died in it like people go really
crazy to get the deals like it's in
intense
and i don't think that's good it's like
oh we're thankful then just kill people
for items
i think it's kind of uh i guess critical
would that be the word i don't know i
don't find all these these these
all these special little thingies
all these special [ __ ]
anymore no okay
oh nice nice oh my gosh it's like
they're all connecting
all right i think that's it
and i'm gonna need you and i'm gonna
need to place another block
down
oh oh
i want to get you
oh you too
okay all right all right boom boom boom
boom boom all right there we go
so yeah i think the i
i really don't like it as a ritual or
whatever you want to call it
but um
yeah since people i've seen videos like
one guy oh
hello hello chasm
one guy got kicked out of walmart when
he was videotaping you might see this on
youtube has a
lot of views he got kicked out because
he was videotaping the people like
beating each other to get the items i
think it's really dumb it's like
you you just spent time being thankful
and then you're just gonna go
hit it whoa for a frame lag
like he says i'm getting like 30 frames
but i know i'm not getting their frames
okay so i'm getting four frames right
now but i'm lagging why am i lagging oh
my god
lagging up a storm
yeah i basically came down here because
i want i want to who was that guys
okay sorry there was just this little
annoying little pop-up thingy i came
down oh oh ow
actually
oh my lag sorry guys i don't know why
it's so laggy
i did come out down here to get uh iron
gravel is something i'm going to need to
make the smelter controller okay i think
we're good all right
yeah also i want to pick up some coal
since
doesn't need that energy bro
i think maybe next episode will go
check out the tree if we finish
everything i want to this episode the
next episode we're going to go hit up
that tree bro all right also just just a
little oh
oh yes you see that you see that i
didn't move my
cursor or mouse wheel to that that i
just moved into my little spot thing
because it's awesome
all right um let's get some more of this
gravel okay so uh
that zombie should be attacking soon
one thing i i wish this mod had auto
switch all of which is like the best
thing ever
break you i'll just replace you
yeah i might as well just get as much
gravel as i can right now
this is all one big gravel tip maybe
let me break all this
and i it is definitely a point that
people can like
yell at america fork in america's
government in many ways how much gravity
up 35
that'll be enough
that's ice i i really don't know how
costly the recipe is
yeah so i think that's a really uh like
and also now
um
it's expanded so that it's not just
the day after thanksgiving like there
there are sales that start at like 6 p.m
on thanksgiving that's like really going
to spend
you gonna spend your day of thanks
waiting in line to beat people to get
material possessions
i i just
i really don't like
as you can tell i have a bias against
black friday yeah i don't know i i've
never i never went to black friday i
never had like personally bad experience
with it
and i actually think it'd be kind of fun
to go since i would just i want to just
like
have fun hitting people like oh you you
just you just knock somebody out to get
that tv let me punch you i feel like
that would be fun
maybe that's just me
i don't know maybe not everybody would
find
eating other people fun however i'm just
i'm not just going crazy just beating
people and beating the people with the
other people so
you got to take into consideration you
know
i don't even know when i started this
video it's really like
look at the top when i start these
videos
probably be more beneficial okay we
spent a while mining and we have 17 iron
that should be good
there's something
look at all the coals i think i'll come
back here and get someone cold i might
as well pick up this oh look at all
these things
oh i just wanted it all
and i want it now
i'm picking up the copper because that's
something that's like
a thing to get for the recipes i'm going
to be using
so okay that should be enough iron
and i have
a perfect stack of coal i'm not going to
get anymore
all right now let's
head back up
i didn't even like explore this way at
all oh my gosh it was iron oh my gosh
yeah i think i think ftb makes iron more
prevalent since it just there's so much
there's look at look at this
they're so much higher
probably because iron like
is weak compared to most of the other
materials
makes sense makes sense why they make it
more oh because this one only goes like
a few inches but it has like six
thousand pounds fire so
fair fair enough
all right oh i didn't forget you since
you're right there oh my gosh more iron
and was that i think that was it okay
now let's
escape the mind i want me to stay here
for days
all right
enough to put like a door or something
yeah i'm definitely gonna make
oh oh oh courts oh it's quartz we're not
like any
quartz crystals like they're they're
semi-rare
and i think they do all the good stuff
oh i'm gonna need to eat uh oh i thought
it was a lamb chopper pork chop i should
know if it's not all green all right so
we have the rubber let's start cooking
up the iron because that's something
we're going to need lots of all right
actually i'm going to make another chest
and oh wow rubber would only give you
three well that makes things awkward
for you would
all right so we're gonna have another
chest
right now it's gonna be a small chest
this will be the uh
mineral chest i think that's all the
minerals
mineral mineral mineral mineral mineral
minerals
okay
all right all right so okay first thing
we gotta do
so
i'm gonna try making the generator first
so over here and
generator that's what we want to
generate so we're going to need a fully
charged arc battery
three pieces of refined iron and iron
furnace or a machine block first machine
block is that much iron so i think i
know what i'm going to do so i'm going
to be like
there we go another furnace
and wow this is taking way too long all
right so i'm going to
i'm going to start cooking with my other
furnace
uh
let me
grab some of that
and actually actually actually
in this furnace we're gonna start
cooking the iron that's what we're gonna
do and i'm gonna need one two three four
five i'm in five pieces so that
technically should be all over yeah so
so you guys probably like what does this
board do in cooking iron but when you
cook iron you get refined iron
fancy i know right yeah yeah
so
you get that refined iron and when you
get that refined i'm actually i'm not
going to control this right now
i'll throw you in there when you get
that refined iron
you know where it's at well you know
where it's at all right so in the
meantime i think i'll make some proper
wire
so if i remember right
it's this
haha six copper cables cables not wires
all right so i think you can throw this
now i'm going to include rubber not
technically mineral but what it should
have been shoot me
all right so
right now i'm going to just make another
furnace because it's easy to make and
place that there then
find iron like that
but wait oh dang it i don't use refined
iron for that i just use normal iron
okay so we have an iron furnace now an
iron furnace is kind of like these
furnaces except it cook cooks faster
so
i'm gonna make more of those regardless
the generator is the iron furnace i've i
have that i have that now the re battery
this is the trickiest parts and i saw
something that kind of was different
from this so re battery it said that you
didn't need a fully charged rd battery
for the generator but i don't know so
yeah oh damn we don't need 10.
dang
wait wait do we do we have anything
we have two pieces of tent
i need more tin than that i think
i need four pieces of tin dang
dang i thought i was gonna be good oh
i found that tin right here oh can you
can you be quietly slime
i don't even ow bad
get back you bet
i don't even care about getting your
slime balls
i kind of want to just run around
looking for over a world
10
symbols
because i don't want to go searching in
the mind i guess
i guess i should really just run down to
the line pick up some 10.
we're going to try building the um
smeltery thingy
and so i'm going to need sand and clay
and so i remember this plate here yes
yes
so i'll pick up all that oh and also get
that
yeah
and then i'll pick up some of this sand
i was talking about black friday i kind
of i kind of like really forgot this
this board oh up up the heels like brown
all right so black friday yeah it's
actually i think i kind of finished
whatever i was going to say about it
it's just it's just dumb
it's all it is
it's like
just endorsed by all the peoples
and they buy it
they just want their monies
and it's really sad
but yeah
there are people that get trapped
stampeded to death and it all sucks for
them and yeah
there's a little glitchy
all right so how much
sand do i have i have 31 sand
uh whatever let's see if it's enough
let's go
let's go home it's good
i think i'll pick up some try and pick
up some 10 10 off camera
i don't know i just don't want to like
search for it for 16 years let's get
three episodes of nada
all right so we have two tin engines
nice but it's not what i wanted all
right so we have all the stuff we need
for
grouts so
some grouts
oh we have 62 things of ground nice
nuts
nice boys wait wait we don't even look
at that we're just looking materials in
you
all right so
i don't know what tool forge is for but
uh
all right so when you cook up grout you
get
the grout bricks seared bricks and four
seed bricks is that and all right i
guess i'll make that tool thing and i'll
make this so we don't we actually don't
need that many so right now i'm just
going to place my iron furnace
and i'm going to put some coal in it and
i'm going to clean up the grout
you see it cooks cooks up a little good
amount faster
it cooks faster cooks that [ __ ] [ __ ]
forge i needed a tool station okay this
thing
right i don't know which one it looks
like
the tool station is
blank
is this one
break it with an axe all right tool
station
and i didn't even look at what else we
need
tool station
oh
oh one two three four blocks of iron oh
oh
well let's cook up our eyebrows
i don't think i'm gonna have enough
i've definitely not had enough for four
blocks
what the heck
was it four blocks of iron oh my gosh
yeah we're definitely going to make the
uh
other thing first
wait wait now
hop oh yeah smeltery controller
i don't know what this does
smelter smeltery
oh i got i got oh making that gave me
mikey smoking all right check this out
introduction casting construction alloys
and recipes all right bye through gone
nice
well that's cool all right so smeltory
is a multi-block structure you will need
the following materials to get started a
controller a tank nine bricks any
combination of tensor bricks to your
tanks or drains one faucet and one
casting table
what the
oh my gosh
okay so um
that's that definitely not gonna work to
place it there
oh crap we'll just break it no no we're
good we're good all right i'll throw my
tool station there since i don't know
what to use it
so i guess we'll we'll do our smell
through this will be our smeltery room
over here
so let me just
clear out some space while everything's
cooking
and yeah so i think this will be good
hopefully yeah it's like two seconds
from my main place so like it'll be okay
um
so let's see what did it look like it's
gonna look like a
one two three
so it's gonna be five by five so one two
three four five
and it takes up a ton of space
let's back it out like two more
and it's gonna be about five so that
about going through there would be five
i could
it's a good thing i actually did get all
that gravity smart decision man nice
thank you no problem
all right so is that going to be big
enough
and i have a little bit of walkway yeah
i had to come on after that one more
just keep moving back hopefully all this
cobblestone will come in handy one day
i can't leave that just for the torch
all right so i'm gonna need
many more blocks so what about i'm gonna
need
one let's how do you make a seared tank
so let's do this and oh nope nope all
right
seared all right see your tank
i'll see your bricks and a piece of
glass and we need to cook some glass
so do you have any sandwich i don't
think i have a single piece of sandwich
i'm gonna go get a single piece of sand
sand
ow i want your soul
i should really be collecting rubber
from these river trees
oh well
let's just pick up like one two three
pieces oh
fancy
i think i'm gonna try and get the
smeltery all
built it up
and then i'll call it today
let's see how far we can get in this
method
yeah i definitely don't have enough for
four blocks i would actually i've
actually had three
need a little more for four maybe if i
didn't make this on first all right here
breaks all right
so
we're gonna need a oh well that we need
a good amount of just
see your bricks
yeah so um we have some glass good
now we can craft
a
see your tank
let's keep all of our stuff better we
are being early like
finished products right here
take some more bricks let me take away
those grouts and throw it here give you
a little more coal
maybe i ran over a dead zombie that's
probably good
throw this stuff in here
yeah
all right all right
so we have our left piece of glass don't
need that though okay so
what do we need what else do we need
okay um nines here bricks any
combination of tents here bricks
tanks or drains
oh i'm confused
all right let's let's do uh faucet
faucet
we'll we'll see the other stuff later
fall
nice see your faucet okay that's easy
it's like a bucket but let's see your
bricks
there we go faucet
and let me take some of you it takes me
i wonder if i'm gonna have enough for
the nine
i don't know
dang i think we need like eighteen zero
bricks dang
no no no
all right so also we needed uh what else
did we need
oh well casting table yeah casting table
r e
delete that falsehood
cast nope
casting
fast basin casting table all right so
i'm just gonna be like that okay that's
simple simple
oh that's wrong
so yeah we can turn the rest of it into
uh
that was loud
breaks
yeah definitely not gonna have enough
yeah that's only eight
because we're gonna need
one two three four five six seven eight
nine one two three four five six seven
eight nine
yeah i think
so there's a faucet oh i think i need a
basin as well
i need a basin and tell me i need a
basin
it doesn't see any basin
are larger basins okay well
serene
there are no vertical restrictions the
size of the basin
large raisins will hold for metal and
the controller can be at any level as
long as there is a lot of tank to match
for liquid metal from the sludge so this
is for like liquid metal
i don't know why i need this
i'm confused
yeah that's that's stuff i know smell
three drain ooh a drain
do you need a drain so your glass
faucet window
basin table
brownstone clear glass
oh a drawbridge you can try very good
later
this this is some crazy stuff guys
there's definitely some crazy stuff
going on here oh what
i'm just gonna break you i don't i don't
like seeing you for days
um i guess we can get started on
creation
uh yes we can make one more block nice
that's nine all right um
yeah i'm just gonna hope this works
and yeah
so we're gonna want the middle thing to
be right there
and let's break this
now let's take you out to you out
you you
no
that
and this can take years to break
a little bit known alright
so let's follow the model to a t
the controller they have right there so
controller
i'll put you like that
yes
all right now that's nuts
all right so um
where did they put the casting table
table
what the heck the other picture don't no
no match
well we put the thingy right next to
that so
put you right there
there's nothing else right here so
there's a little view
and faucet i'm going to need some space
for the faucet so
break this
i will light you up a little bit oh my
actually more of you
um the false is the last thing
so
apparently place that anywhere so we're
going to put the faucet back actually i
know it's not but it's special so we're
going to keep it there all right now i
think
i don't know i'm going to conclude this
video there i'll do some work on the
side so you'll get some more grout
hopefully finds a pin
and then i'll put it all together in the
next video so you guys hope you enjoyed
this video if you did make sure you
leave a like or a comment or subscribe
like if you got all the way to the end
of this video i have no idea how long it
was it could have been 15 minutes could
have been 25 minutes uh it could have
been two well i know it's not a few
minutes don't worry don't worry i'm
smart boy
hope you all enjoyed if you did make
sure you leave a like rate comment or
subscribe and i'll see you all later
peace
rainbow all the way